x plus 10 squared is correct. Great job if you got that one right. If you're a
little stumped, then stay with me and we'll figure this out together. You
might've also put x plus 10 times x plus 10, which is also correct. We have the
same factor listed twice, so we could've just written it as x plus 10 squared.
This expression follows this factoring pattern. The first term is a perfect
square. Since x squared is x squared, and the last term is also a perfect
square. Since 10 squared is 100. So the a is really x, and the b is really 10.
This means that we can rewrite this expression as x squared plus 2 times x times
10 plus 10 squared. We know this perfect square trinomial can be written as a
binomial squared. So, we really have x plus 10 squared. Don't worry if you
didn't get this first one right, there'll be more to come.